you have to learn to perform without
motivation you have to learn to perform
without purpose you have to learn to
perform a lot of different things and
that's what people think they think I
need to have this motivation to work out
to study to be better so if they don't
have it they just don't do it and that's
where you fail you have to learn to
train your mind well beyond motivation
if you have motivation that's great
that's some can lean to the fire all it
takes is a little bit of spark you can
burn the whole Forest up you have to be
your best self and your least motivated
and that's the tricky part about all
that motivation is just a word